how about jalen ramsey we knew this guy
was a good player for a long time wait
wait wait wait wait wait you see he
played good but this was a whole nother
level jalen ramsey and we've seen it all
from this guy what'd you think from him
tonight rod i thought he was awesome i
thought raheem morris did a great job of
moving him around playing them on the
outside playing them on the inside he
got a couple tackle for losses man where
you get that mean streak from cause
you're just a dog you ain't no
cornerback though you're a safety
hey man i'm just i'm blessed man you
know god has blessed me um with so much
man with so much talent so
me just honoring him is just going and
working hard developing my skill you
know trying to be a leader to my
teammates and coach uh he's utilizing me
in ways that i've never been utilized
before you know so i'm just out there
having an extremely fun time honestly
the first time inside this packed house
here at sofi what was the feeling
walking out oh it was electric oh yeah
it was nice in here last year was a
little different a little weird you know
what i mean uh i feel like we still
played well but this year with the with
the energy in the crowd like we feed off
of that so i'm excited you know for for
the rest of our home games too for them
to show up and show out i mean you look
at matthew stafford what does he get big
nine did it
big plays down the field what does he
bring to this team oh man uh
man just
one of the best leaders i've ever been
around like he controls and has a
command of that offense like i've never
seen before him and sean they got their
little thing they doing it together and
man you see them connecting on deep
passes no look passes
his ball placement is crazy just how
where he's putting it for the receiver
to catch it and only the receiver to be
able to catch it so he's doing things
like that that challenges us in practice
to be the best and we like to think that
we're the best in the in the game so we
like to feel like we challenging him as
well and we hope it is working like that
amen coach staley heads over to coach
the chargers on the other side of la
what's different about your role in this
defense this year how are they moving
you around what feels different from
your perspective uh yeah i'm just uh
i guess trying to be utilized so where
teams can't shy away from me as much so
i can get in a little action so i can
get in some run fits make some tfls be
on the perimeter control the perimeter a
little bit and then also i'm still
getting out on the edge that's where i
love to be so i'm having fun doing all
of that honestly and and they just
utilizing me they they see that my value
is there
so uh why minimize it why pictures hold
me to one thing when i can do so much
brother we gotta watch the film maybe
the play that that was just uh
attack the tackle on the tight end kind
of open space that's a really tough
tackle um that most people wouldn't
understand but i was able to stand them
up and my teammates was able to rally
here and come help me secure that tackle
either that one or the bubble play now
you and aaron donald get most of all the
attention but tell me about or give me
one player on your defense that a lot of
people don't know about it's gonna be
that one give me one give me three give
me four give me something i'm gonna go
you know i'm gonna go with my dbs i'm
gonna go with jordan fuller d-will d-lo
they ball in d-lo he came right yeah
d-lo had his pick today okay you know
and in the secondary me and d will we
kind of made our name for ourselves in
the league a little bit and uh dilo not
too many people knew about him we very
confident in him obviously he was out
here today on that first drive when they
drove it down here on us
he turned it up they got a turnover he
got an interception however it happened
he popped the year off for us i'm super
happy for him and jordan fuller man he
got the green dot you know i mean he out
there calling plays that's something
tough to do from the safety spot you
gotta kind of control and have a command
of the whole defense he's doing a great
job only in year two doing that you know
what i mean um and then you got taylor
rapp who just disruptive in all phases
and the communication from our safety's
down to everybody else is just great
honestly and i'm just talking about the
secondary right now because they're my
guys but i can really talk about the
whole defense jalen just take me inside
that locker room coach mcvay now you
have stafford in the building yourself
a.d mr donald all these guys what's the
vibe inside that building it looks good
personalities right
we got some personalities in there but
uh it all clicks and it all gels
everybody is able to beat themselves uh
well you know it's not like that in some
places yeah it's a vibe you know it's
just a a good energy a good vibe that we
have around there everybody is serious
about ball but when we're not playing
football we can interact and we can we
can have good times but when it's time
to work we're going to work as well
everybody got that same mindset jalen i
know you're a very emotional player but
when you get overboard who's that one
guy on the team that can kind of pull
you to the side and calm you down and
get you back focused a.d for sure
hey i i got a i got a big brother shout
out to my big brother back home
but uh
a.d is like a big brother out here on
this field to me um in a lot of ways and
a lot of the ways honestly just the way
he goes about his business yeah i don't
even really got to say much but at times
adi can come holla at me and you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna respect that that's
walking he's inspiring isn't it yeah
inspiring now i don't even know if
inspiring is the right word he different
he's just he's special man god bless him
you mentioned your brother back home
you're a father now too how was your
fatherhood congratulations perspective
man i love my daughters you know i mean
i got three beautiful daughters they're
so amazing um
they love each other i love their love
uh a daughter daughter and father love
is different it's totally different
obviously i want a son one day what's it
like what's it like as man it uh it
brings me like a peace yeah it brings me
uh a patience in my life that i that i
desperately needed um
and uh it's just so much fun you know
sometimes i still get a little rough
with them but most of the time i gotta
go home and have tea parties and playing
their little barbie doll houses and
stuff it's a different aspect that
people don't get to see but i love every
minute of it like look at her she's so
beautiful oh she is beautiful that's my
oh thank god she looked like a mom oh
yeah
she's so beautiful though
all of my daughters so beautiful it was
always amazing to me that the nfl wasn't
in l.a so take us behind the curtain
what is it like with the nfl being on
the premier team really right now in the
city of los angeles yeah honestly uh
when you think of la and la sports you
think of like champions and historic
teams and franchises so you know i
wasn't here when when they start when
they came back to la from the beginning
i was in jacksonville but being able to
come out here it was so kind of
rejuvenating to my career and just my
energy and my soul and it's and it's
been it's been great it's been
everything that i hoped it would be and
dreamed it would be
football is football but something
special about playing on sunday night oh
yeah how do you feel when you get a
chance to play in front of the world oh
watching sunday night pack crowd here no
millions watching on tv it's the
greatest villain ever you want to go out
there you want to honor god you want to
let his light shine through you that's
right you want to let all the people out
there see who you really are what you
all capable of not only yourself but
your teammates too and i feel like we
did that tonight you know it's just week
one so we got a lot of a lot of mistakes
to correct i'm gonna say a lot but we
got we got some mistakes to correct and
some things to clean up but man it was a
blessing to just be out here and come
away with the win my last question yeah
do you guys talk about super bowl
because most teams ah it's kind of taboo
of course but do you feel like you can
reach the super bowl now that you have
this quarterback of course of course
that's always the goal um and of course
if if you got big dreams and you got big
goals you're gonna talk about it
sometimes you're gonna you're gonna
bring it up that's always what we're
pushing for when when things get tough
maybe when practice gets hard out here
during the game it gets hard we gotta
remember in the back of our minds what
we're really doing is what we're doing
it for each other we're doing it to
reach a super bowl and win a super bowl
so we uh we got all the players we got
all the pieces here we just got to
continue to put it together continue
growing um but yeah we talk about it
here and there we don't try to harp on
it because you know we got to go week by
week that's right you can't win the
super bowl today in september october
november you can't win it right now so
it's a long play but you know everything
that we're doing right now is taking
steps to be there at the end of the time
man nothing but admiration for i
appreciate you appreciate you making all
the best
i remember the last time we were selling
houses
right that's exactly right man you seem
great mentally physically your game
seems awesome no doubt congratulations
on everything thank you he's a safety i
don't care what they say he is saying
hey i'm a db just throw it out that's
not going to be he's a football player
that's right that's what he is a pure
appreciation i really appreciate all the
best to you bro
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports